[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera a tutte ea tutti e come potete
leggere questa sera vi parlerò di salute
e prima di iniziare a parlarvi di salute
vi vorrei dire qualcosa su di me perché
penso sia importante partire da lì per
lasciarvi poi degli spunti
sull'argomento e io sono un medico sono
un medico specialista in alimentazione e
mi occupo di
obesità di metabolismo e di disturbi del
comportamento alimentare sono anche un
ricercatore sono un dottorando di
ricerca in endocrinologia il metabolismo
e in andrologia e poi gli sono anche
edoardo eduardo è un giovane ragazzo gay
e perché vi dico questo perché per me
appartenere a una categoria discriminata
e stato importante per riconoscerne
un'altra quando poi sono entrato a
contatto nell'ambito del mio lavoro con
il tema dell'obesità il tema della tv il
tema dei corpi grassi perché io l'ho
riconosciuta subito quella roba da
quando l'ho incontrata la
marginalizzazione la discriminazione
l'ho riconosciuta nelle parole delle
persone che ho visitato nelle esperienze
in quello che avevano passato in quello
che avevano vissuto
e quando si parla di femminismo
intersezionale che per quanti di voi
hanno familiarità con il termine e cioè
del fatto che le categorie le
caratteristiche e le persone che
appartengono a categorie diverse
discriminate e marginalizzate in fondo
fanno la stessa lotta e sono tutte lotte
con interconnesse tra loro
mi sono accorto che di fatto c'era una
categoria di persone che avevano
che appartenevano una categoria e che
avevano una caratteristica che però non
veniva riconosciuta come tale per
diversi motivi
e questa caratteristica il grasso
e non c'è il tempo qui per approfondire
in maniera ampia e ragionevole quello
che il tema della grasso fobia che un
tema enorme e avete la possibilità di
approfondirlo attraverso il lavoro di
attivisti e attiviste e attraverso
numerosi testi che trattano il tema però
sicuramente si può dire che la radice
della grasso fobia è in tre grandi
filoni di discriminazione e cioè il
sessismo e razzismo il classismo è una
cosa dovete darmela per buona e cioè il
fatto che
l'odio per il grasso nella nostra
società nasce prima che il grasso
diventasse anche una preoccupazione per
la salute pubblica
perché questa è la domanda che poi in
fondo sta già nascendo dentro di voi ed
è la domanda che io mi sono sentito
rivolgere sempre ogni volta che parlavo
di questo tema perché parlo tanto e ne
ho parlato tanto perché nel momento in
cui si realizza quello che ho realizzato
come medico è impossibile non sentire
l'urgenza comunicativa di parlare di
questa cosa qui ne ho parlato tantissimo
apparenti consenti amici fino a dover
fare un profilo instagram probabilmente
è stato silenziato da parenti conoscenti
amici dove parlo tanto di questo tema e
è impossibile non parlarne dicevo perché
fondamentalmente c'è una narrazione che
inganna ed è una narrazione che va
smontata pezzo per pezzo
e è molto molto radicata dentro di noi
per cui è difficile uscirne po come uno
di quei quadri che devi guardare con una
certa visuale per far uscire l'immagine
tridimensionale per cui dovete fare uno
sforzo e dobbiamo fare un percorso
insieme
innanzitutto la prima cosa da dire è che
le persone grasse sono sempre esistite e
c'è una variabilità dei corpi e delle
forme corporee
e il numero delle persone con corpi
grassi è aumentato e questo sicuramente
è aumentato perché è cambiata la società
è una parte della popolazione è
suscettibile ai cambiamenti che ci sono
stati nella società e quindi si è vista
ingrassare in percentuale siamo più
grassi di quanto non fossimo prima
però una variabilità di corti c'e sempre
stata e dei corpi grassi ci sono sempre
stati
e l'altra faccia di finché dobbiamo
considerare quando si parla di una
narrazione sbagliata il fatto che si
considera una scelta anche qui c'è una
connessione con la comunità lgbt cooper
che chiunque lo stesso appartenga alla
comunità si è sentito dire tu che hai
fatto questa scelta io non ho fatto
nessuna scelta e allo stesso modo quando
si parla di corpi grassi si considerano
le persone con corti grassi persone che
hanno un difetto morale che hanno scelto
di essere grasse quando potevano
scegliere diversamente invece hanno
scelto poiché sono difettose moralmente
di essere grasse è in realtà non è così
non è facile non è così semplice non si
può scegliere in maniera così automatica
pur potendo influenzare sicuramente il
proprio corpo e il proprio peso e la
propria percentuale di massa grassa però
non è così automatico perché quando si
considerano quelle che sono le cause
della nostra percentuale adiposa o con
questa della nostra forma corporea del
nostro corpo
va considerato il fatto che molte delle
cause sono esterne ai singoli individui
e anche tra quelle che sono interne agli
individui non sempre sono modificabili
dalle persone
e questo è stato anche la
giustificazione per la pressione di
alcuni modelli estetici che a volte sono
stati mascherati da l'idea della salute
perché si è detto fondamentalmente non
devi essere grasso è un modello estetico
si però pensiamo anche alla salute
quindi vi fa bene se non siete grassi e
quando si parla di modelli estetici
di fatto ci hanno imposto il desiderio
di non essere grassi ma badate bene
neanche lontanamente grassi perché
l'omogeneità dei modelli estetici
estremamente pressante e quando si parla
di un bisogno cioè il bisogno che ci
hanno inculcato di non essere grassi
nella società dei consumi
inevitabilmente da domani nasce offerta
e quindi è nata l'industria delle diete
i prodotti dietetici le diete stesse ma
anche alcuni programmi di fitness tutto
quanto potesse permetterci di sfuggire
al terrore di essere grassi e quando si
parla di diete è importante capire di
che cosa parliamo le diete oggi sono sui
settimanali
allora non che ieri sono in tv e oggi
sono su internet sulle app sono alla
portata di tutti e questo momento anche
la narrazione per cui perché sei grasso
fai una dieta che ci vuole sta sul
settimanale basta che tu fai questa
dieta e poi non sei più in questo modo
in cui non devi essere è in realtà
quando si parla di diete bisognerebbe
comprendere che sono strumenti clinici
molto potenti e potenzialmente anche
molto dannosi e non è una cosa nuova che
ho scoperto io recentemente qualcosa che
conosciamo da sempre e che la lettera di
quella letteratura è abbastanza concorde
e già 70 anni fa
ansell kiss che è stato poi uno dei
padri della dieta mediterranea nello
studio della dieta mediterranea
ricercatore americano che ha svolto un
esperimento che si chiama il minnesota
starvation experiment che ha visto
arruolare 36 persone tra coloro che non
volevano arruolarsi per il servizio
militare scelte tra 100 volontari scelti
tra i più forti sia fisicamente che
psicologicamente
e ha fatto un esperimento che mirava
fondamentalmente a capire come curare le
persone che venivano dalla guerra che
potevano essere state sottoposte a
periodi di digiuno di restrizione
calorica e quindi un ambiente simulato
di dieta e queste 36 persone sono state
studiate nel loro comportamento
alimentare nella loro vita alimentare
sotto tutti i punti di vista e dopo di
che sono state sottoposte a un periodo
di restrizione calorica di circa sei
mesi di circa la metà delle calorie che
erano stati studiati introdurre con
delle quantità di calorie insomma si
trovano nello studio che vi assicuro
sono assolutamente paragonabili con la
quantità di calorie che potete trovare
sulle diete nei settimanali anche oggi
in edicola
e i risultati
che sono stati poi analizzati in un
periodo di riabilitazione nutrizionale
ma anche dopo sono stati sorprendenti
non tanto per risultati organici che ci
sono stati su individui che hanno perso
peso il che era prevedibile ma anche per
i risultati psicologici sociali e
comportamentali
perché
le persone hanno cambiato il loro modo
di vivere durante un periodo di
restrizione calorica innanzitutto più
della metà dei partecipanti
nessuno di loro era interessato
argomenti di cucina hanno cominciato a
leggere libri di ricette a interessarsi
alla di mentazione la fissazione
sull'alimentazione che qualcosa che chi
ha provato una dieta restrittiva
sicuramente ha vissuto e poi ci sono
stati dei cambiamenti dei comportamenti
dal punto di vista del comportamento
alimentare quindi un consumo di grandi
quantità di liquidi per tenere lo
stomaco piano commento del tabagismo ma
anche un consumo di gomme da masticare
con alcuni e degli partecipanti allo
studio che hanno consumato più di 40
perché ti dico come al giorno e inoltre
ci sono stati dei cambiamenti
psicologici perché
innanzitutto non tutti sono riusciti a
seguire quelle che erano le istruzioni e
quindi ci sono stati dei veri e propri
comportamenti bulimici degli episodi
bulimici seguiti da auto rimprovero auto
deprecazione e dei sintomi depressivi
dei sintomi di isolamento sociale
in un caso c'è stato anche un episodio
psicotico con un autobus moti lamento
quindi capite bene che quando si parla
di diete parliamo di qualcosa di
delicato di estremamente potente che può
avere un effetto sulle persone e che
sicuramente può avere un effetto sulla
salute
con questo non voglio dire che tutte le
dette sono sbagliate o che non si
possono fare le diete in alcuni contesti
in alcuni momenti o che non possono
anche essere utili dal punto di vista
terapeutico
però sicuramente vanno fatte da qualcuno
che sa quello che sta facendo non
possono stare sui settimanali da te così
a tutti e quando si parla di salute a
questo punto capite quanto sia
importante fare un passo indietro a
chiedersi che cos'è la salute perché se
la dieta non agisce in maniera così
diretta sulla salute perché tutti quanti
avete visto che cosa è successo a quelle
persone
capite che gli effetti che avete visto
in alcuni di loro si sono protratti nel
tempo
avete capito che intuitivamente che non
è aumentata la loro salute
e quindi dobbiamo chiederci che cos'è la
salute e quando parliamo di salute c'è
una definizione dell'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità che ci dice che la
salute è un completo stato di benessere
un completo stato di benessere fisico
psicologico sociale spirituale
che una definizione molto bella che è
cambiata nel tempo e che sicuramente una
bella definizione da utilizzare quando
si lavora anche come professionisti
sanitari e
quando si pensa a una definizione di
questo tipo si arriva a comprendere che
non ha nessun senso rivolgersi alla
popolazione intera ponendo come unico
obiettivo il raggiungimento di un peso
forma il raggiungimento di un peso il
raggiungimento di un obiettivo
metabolico internistico a qualunque
costo
perché non ci stiamo occupando di ogni
aspetto e quindi possiamo considerare la
salute con questa concezione non come
una lavagna sul quale scrivere le
diagnosi o i fattori di rischio
ma piuttosto come un prisma e un prisma
quando
brilla e perché tutte le facce sono
pulite limpide e ben curate e imprese ma
che è diverso per ognuno di noi perché
ognuno di noi avrà il suo prisma
corrispondente alla sua salute
un prisma in cui alcuni avranno una
faccia un po più grande alcuni una
faccia un po più piccola però sempre un
prisma e un prisma in cui però se noi
trascuriamo danneggiamo nel tentativo
addirittura a volte di volerlo
salvaguardare di voler promuovere il
nostro benessere
finiamo per danneggiare una delle facce
il prisma finisce per non brillare più
e quindi capite quanto
quando pensiamo alla salute
quando pensiamo al tema dei corpi grassi
questa cosa riguarda tutti noi perché
tutti quanti noi conosciamo siamo stati
persone che per seguire un certo ideale
di peso corporeo o di forma corporea
giustificata anche da un certo ideale di
salute ci siamo finiti per danneggiare
altri aspetti della nostra salute
e il messaggio che secondo me è
importante che passi per tutte le
persone con cui vorrei lasciarvi e che
credo che sia importante che passi per
le persone comuni ma anche per i
professionisti sanitari e che in
qualunque momento della vostra vita o
del vostro lavoro vi trovate a occuparvi
di benessere delle persone e non vi
preoccupate di ogni faccia del prisma
della salute in quel momento non vi
state occupando di salute grazie
[Applauso]